Today we continue our discussion of impracticability and now impossibility by
learning about the case of Taylor versus Caldwell.
This is another landmark English contract law case,
which helped to establish an important common law doctrine.
It was decided by the court of Queens bench in 1863 I,
during the US civil war,
the opinions author Justice Blackburn was a highly respected judge who is
remembered for his work on contracts,
common law.
Before we get to the facts of the case,
let's review two key terms.
The doctrine of impracticability is a common law doctrine that excuse
performance of the duty.
When that duty became unfeasibly difficult,
uh,
or expensive,
you might hear a separate and related doctrine.
The doctrine of impossibility mentioned in the context of Taylor versus Caldwell
case,
impossibilities impracticability on steroids.
It excuses performance where the duty cannot be physically performed.
In other words,
the excuse of impossibility is raised when there's no way for performance to be
accomplished.
The excuse to have impracticability,
which we talked about in the last,
uh,
video applies when performance is still possible,
but only at an unreasonable cost while not identical.
These are certainly similar and intertwined concepts in Taylor versus Caldwell.
The defendant Caldwell agreed to license the music hall to plaintiff Taylor so
that Taylor could host concerts and major events at the venue before these
concerts were held and before the plaintiff had paid the defendant,
the music hall burned down without the fault of either party.
Taylor versus Caldwell is famous for helping to establish the common law defense
of impossibility.
The main issue presented is this,
given that the agreement failed to anticipate the destruction of the music hall
was defendant hall loner,
the Hall loaner still obligated to perform or pay damages he couldn't perform,
so it comes down to is it's still obligated to pay damages.
The court held that know the defendant is not on the hook for the contract after
the music hall fire.
Reasoning that the parties could not reasonably be expected to anticipate every
unlikely occurrence.
The court announces that the contract contained an implied or default condition
excusing the parties from performance.
If the hall ceased to exist,
the court treated the existence of the music hall as an implicit condition.
Let's try a quiz for the existence of the music hall to be an implicit
condition.
Does it matter if the parties actually contemplated it?
In other words,
did the parties need to have the implicit condition in their minds at the time
performing the contract?
Well,
no.
It usually doesn't matter whether the parties actually had this implicit
condition in mind.
The inquiry usually focuses on what reasonable people would have intended rather
than what the parties actually thought about the implied condition that the
music hall would still exists is implied by force of law and not because the
parties had it in mind.
Recall that the efficient risk bear analysis suggests that a risk should be
allocated to the party who's best able to bear the risk.
How does the Taylor v Caldwell case square with this concern of economic
efficiency?
While the rule that the continued existence of the thing necessary for
performances and implied condition ignores whether the defendant promissor may
be the better bearer of the risk of the thing perishing.
For instance,
if the hall owner is in the best position to prevent a fire to the music call,
say by having regular patrols or reducing smoking nearby,
then it might make sense from a,
uh,
efficient risk bearer analysis to have the hollowing or bear the risk of the
hall burning down.
However,
remember that this case is a case where the fire happened,
quote without fault of either party and quote.
So perhaps there is no superior risk.
Bear in this particular case,
at any rate,
justice Blackburn has definitely was definitely more influenced by the civil law
then by considerations of economic efficiency when he decided this case,
Taylor versus Caldwell establishes the common law roots of an impracticability
defense and it remains important in modern contracts.
Section two six one of the second restatement allows him practice the
impracticability defense to discharge a party's duty to perform.
And Section two six three specifically discusses cases where an object's
existence is necessary for performance.
If the existence of a physical object is necessary for performance,
then it is viewed as a basic assumption and and implicit condition upon which
the contract is made.
If the physical object does not exist,
then performance is impracticable and the duty to perform is discharged.
If the Taylor case was decided today,
then whether the particular music hall is necessary for performance is an
important inquiry.
If the court finds that the burn hall was necessary for the performance and that
other halls weren't reasonable substitutes,
then the fire would discharge the owner's duty to provide a hall.
Another major category of impracticability is the death or incapacity of
unessential person.
As with restatement section two six three the key question is to determine
whether the particular person is necessary for the performance of the duty.
The question of who is necessary may be determined by the agreement or if the
agreement is silent and assessment of whether the performance was a personal
matter requiring personal experience,
ability,
skill and judgment.
Under this test,
the death of an artist employed to paint a portrait would discharge the
contract,
but the death of the subject of the portrait would not discharge a duty to pay
the agreed price.
Another way to determine who is necessary is to ask whether the person who dies
or was incapacitated could have delegated his or her duty to a third party
without the other party's consent.
The question is whether the other party has a substantial interest in having the
contract performed by the this particular person.
If so,
the contract is discharged.
For instance,
the death of the contractor might not excuse con a contract to do construction
work,
but death of an attorney likely would discharge a,
a contract with a law firm,
but since people rather than corporations die or become incapacitated and become
incapacitated,
the question remains whether the performance to be rendered was so personal in
nature that it could not have been discharged in Taylor versus Caldwell.
Was this a case of supervening or existing impracticability.
Okay.
Well,
this is a case of supervening impracticability meaning the events giving rise to
the impracticability occurred after the formation of the contract.
The difference between supervening and existing impracticability is an important
one for analyzing economic efficiency.
The difference lies in the opportunity for one or both parties to know at the
time of contracting whether the risk event has occurred for existing
impracticability,
the promise or may know or have reason to know that the risk has already
materialized.
So it's difficult to conclude that the promise or did not assume it put another
way.
When existing impracticability is involved,
it's easier to determine which party was in the best position when information
costs are considered to ascertain the exact state of things.
If the promised her was,
uh,
has that information,
he or she may now be the superior risk bear.
Okay.
In summary,
Taylor v Caldwell is a common law case that introduces the doctrine of
impossibility,
which excuses performance when the duty becomes impossible.
Uh,
in particular,
the existence of the thing necessary for performance is seen as an implied
condition to the contract.
This also applies to the existence of a person necessary to a contract.